it's the first time we're seeing an
attack of this scale after the irgc
leader qasim suleimani was killed in
baghdad and ballistic missiles were
fired both in northern iraq and towards
u.s cons u.s facilities military
facilities that is in iraq so far no
official confirmation whether these 12
missiles were fired by iran but what
we're hearing from officials is that an
investigation has been ordered to try
and figure out where these missiles came
from and what was the motives uh what we
know from us and iraqi officials is that
there was no damage caused by these 12
missiles which hit around midnight iraqi
time on the outskirts of erbil that is
the
capital of the semi-autonomous
region of kurdistan there's been swift
condemnation from the kurdish prime
minister mr barzani calling it a
terrorist attack we're hearing from the
iraqi prime minister saying that an
investigation has been ordered and also
condemnation from
the powerful cleric whose political bloc
has secured the highest number of seats
after october's elections worth
remembering that there is still no
official government since october after
these elections took place
what we do not know is what was the
motive behind these attacks there has
been uh targeting of irgc uh commanders
and officials in syria in recent days uh
we also know that this is coming at a
critical juncture of iran's relations
with the outside world where the talks
in vienna about nuclear
the nuclear deal have been suspended we
also know that it also comes at the
heels of heightened military tensions
across the globe as iran continues to
remain an important ally for russia